you gotta take calculated risks
what if i hire the wrong person you will
like i actually promise you
once you step into hiring like not
everyone's gonna work out and that's not
even necessarily
says anything about the individual it
just might not be a good fit
welcome to the think media podcast my
name is heather torres and i'm so
excited that you're here for today's
episode this podcast if you're brand new
we are here to help you build your
youtube influence and then take that
influence and build a high impact and a
high profit online business and today's
episode is going to help you do just
that sean cannell's going to be diving
into a topic that we actually cover in
one of our programs called inner circle
shout out to all the ic fam listening
right now so excited that you're here
we're gonna be talking about how to hire
now you may think this isn't for me i'm
not even there yet but let me tell you
if you've got a vision for your youtube
channel then this is the episode for you
because this is what separates those who
can make it kind of on youtube and those
that actually make it happen on youtube
so i'm excited for you to jump into
today's episode and then we'll do a
quick recap at the very end so let's
jump into today's episode all about how
to hire
[Music]
thinking about hiring someone for your
youtube channel may have really never
crossed your mind before or it may seem
super out of reach like when are you
ready to hire what are the details of
actually finding someone to hire how
much should you pay them and i'm excited
to get into those topics because
ultimately when it comes to creating
youtube content there's three seasons
the first season is the side hustle
season usually you're going to be doing
this by yourself i mean you've got a job
you've got school
maybe you've got a family member or a
spouse or a partner or brother or sister
helping you but you're probably doing
everything you're wearing all the hats
you're doing everything all by yourself
and that's usually where most of us
start eventually we might move into the
solopreneur season where now we're
actually making a living maybe we don't
have to work our job anymore maybe we're
able to work on youtube full time but we
still may be by ourselves we still may
be trying to wear all the hats and in
addition to youtube you're trying to
build websites you're trying to manage
social media you're trying to answer all
the comments plan your videos build out
products find ways to monetize it's a
lot but also ultimately we need to get
into the scale season and that scale
season is where we scale beyond
ourselves one is too small of a number
for long-term greatness so we need to
start getting help
for our youtube channel so i actually
have seven mindsets that have helped me
because this has been one of my biggest
struggles i've been the mr superman
syndrome i don't know if you've ever if
you've heard of superman syndrome before
that's where like i could just do it all
i can just it'll be faster for me to
just do it by myself you know i you know
i'll learn how to edit i'll learn how to
make thumbnails i'll learn how to do all
that stuff and i think that's valuable
because eventually you can train others
or figure out how you want to do it but
ultimately i delayed hiring i delayed
delegating and i had to actually rework
my mindset change some limiting beliefs
and so in a second i want to of course
answer the question
when should you hire someone to help
with your youtube channel but i think we
should start with these seven mindsets
and commitments and number one is this
i will commit to growing as a leader and
building a team
i think that'll serve you even if you've
never thought about that before that
today you would say you know what i am
going to commit to grow as a leader
well let's attack that do you think of
yourself as a leader maybe you've never
thought of yourself as a leader before i
believe that making a commitment to
being a leader growing as a leader
learning leadership and thinking about
the power of leadership in your life
because listen as you grow in a leader
you're going to be a better friend
you're going to be a better spouse
you're going to be a better employee
you're going to be a better person to
all those around you but ultimately it
is going to be a skill set that you need
if you're ever going to have a team or
if you're ever going to keep a team you
may be able to hire a team but they
won't stick with you because you've
never developed those leadership skills
so even if you actually don't make your
first hire for one year even if you
don't make your first hire for five
years you want to start working on
leadership today and secondly i will
commit to building a team
even if you don't actually hire
your first person for three years
you should start growing and thinking
about and shifting your mindset towards
i need to build a team that was one of
the initial commitments i made i started
reading books on teamwork started
studying teamwork started studying
leadership years before i actually ever
hired somebody i started to immerse
myself to say man how i i was i was a
team member you can learn a lot being on
a team you can learn a lot being an
employee being in an organization being
an intern studying and just absorbing
details from around you but one of the
reasons why you want to commit to
growing as a leader is because of what's
called the law of magnetism
who you are
is who you attract
now listen you can hire a va or maybe
someone that edits some videos and you
send them the files in dropbox or use
something like vid chops which is a
service that will help you edit videos
chances are your leadership abilities
aren't going to like make or break that
relationship but someday
if you are really going to build a
healthy team
who you are is who you attract if you
say man i just can't find good people
well are you a good person i just can't
find people that are healthy i i seem to
i have toxic people all around you well
sometimes you got to look in the mirror
i mean the law of magnetism would say
well maybe maybe you're toxic i mean i
hope you wear warrior still-toed boots
today because you didn't know i was
going to step on your toes but
ultimately the law of magnetism so all
this is is a commitment that i want to
grow
because i want to attract good people
ambitious people creative people people
that value excellence people that are
pursuing world-class people and so
number one i'm just making this
commitment this whole remember this is a
marathon not a sprint
and so don't just judge your life and
your youtube channel by one chapter of
the book like where are you going to be
in five years where are you going to be
in 10 years it's going to serve you to
commit to becoming a leader and growing
as a leader and building a team today
even if it doesn't unfold
for a while number two i will slow down
so i can ultimately speed up the problem
with hiring
it may not just be money but i'm sure
that's one of the challenges right
but it may be i just don't have any time
to actually hire anyone i just don't
have any time to actually look for
someone to hire and if i hire somebody i
don't have any time to train anyone i
just i don't have any time listen
make a commitment i'm gonna slow down so
that i can ultimately speed up
the reality is
your life's not going to get any simpler
the demands of growing a youtube channel
a youtube business a content business
being a youtube entrepreneur it doesn't
actually get any simpler there's only
going to be more things to do tomorrow
you were already trying to do one video
a week now you're doing a video a week a
live stream a week a video podcast a
week and now you feel like you need to
do youtube shorts things are just going
to get more
complex and there's going to be more
things to do
so are you planting seeds today
for the harvest that you want to reap
tomorrow
that
effort should be invested in ultimately
building a team or putting some systems
or even and remember a team might be a
service again a team might be just
delegating editing something like vid
chops and we'll link up some show notes
and resources in this episode that's a
great um you know service that you can
dropbox your your files to and they'll
start editing your videos for you what
happened you just recovered a few hours
a week you might hire a virtual
assistant on a website like upwork.com
and they help you do some email inbox
management for five hours a week you're
regaining your time but listen it's
gonna take you slowing down
to train them on board them figure it
out it's not perfect at first it will
actually go slower at first and this is
why most don't do it you start working
with an editor you send them the footage
they send you the video back you go
they couldn't read my mind forget it i'm
just going to edit it myself of course
they can't read your mind dude you
actually have to take some time to slow
down hear me
so that ultimately you can speed up
and i love we talked about this in a
past podcast there's a mantra for the
navy seals they have a philosophy that
slow is smooth
and smooth is fast
so actually sometimes going slower in
this frantic social media culture
actually means you're speeding just
being busy does not mean you're being
effective
slow down what really matters how can
you build systems and a team a few
people a part-time contractor some
systems and services that will help you
just automate some of the things that
you're doing so that ultimately you can
speed up and see more revenue coming in
more subscribers coming in more view
views coming in number two i will slow
down so that i can ultimately speed up
number three
i will delegate and not dump
on the journey of building a team and
hiring this is where people fail first
of all they don't slow down to actually
train the person then they actually
maybe finally go okay i'm going to hire
that editor again they're just going to
read my mind so what i'm going to do is
just dump everything on them all right
here you go good luck and you actually
don't properly delegate a lot of
entrepreneurs and youtube entrepreneurs
especially in the early stage
they they delegate quote unquote and
then they disappear
like and then they're surprised that
that person didn't do it the way that
they wanted it done and that it now it's
like more frustrating
well hear me
think media podcast community
you're the problem
like you just you are the problem no my
editor's the problem you don't
understand no you you are because first
of all you hired him so that might have
been your hiring process and who you
selected i went with the cheapest person
on upwork that's probably why their
editing is so bad like but secondly
you got to take extreme ownership
regardless because if you think
everybody else is the problem you've
just given away your personal power
you have to say okay i'm going to take
responsibility to slow down help the
person or be patient in the process okay
cool they turn in an edit this week it's
like at a six out of ten but at least
you're making some progress and having
someone help you then you're like hey
let's make these tweaks and next week
it's a seven out of ten the next week
it's an eight out of ten you'd be
surprised how much progress you can make
in one month and then all of a sudden
you're like man i don't even have to
like submit edits to them anymore you
know when i've delegated editing over
the years work with multiple different
editors there's been times where i've
written time code by time code at 7
seconds at 12 seconds exact edit that i
want done typically in a google doc
change this here fix the audio here do a
little swish thing here this is
misspelled here this needs to be rolled
as edit was super janky here this didn't
look very good here this pacing felt
weird here and i wrote like a page and a
half of notes
to people and and and that made i had to
slow down
but
eventually
i'm sending no notes and now i'm working
on something entirely different and
we're at a whole nother pace and
that editor is also like and here and i
just they made things better than i
could have ever imagined but it
sometimes takes time
right so you delegate something you just
you don't just dump it here you go good
luck like you gotta actually follow up
with the person
and inspect
what you expect
number four
i will check my ego and trust others
as my favorite one i get it resources
might be one of the challenges with
hiring but you know what one of the big
blockers is ego this is what i suffered
from
because here's my background too one of
the hardest things to delegate is maybe
one of the main skills you've developed
now your background's probably different
than mine i happen to be a video editor
since like 2002.
so youtube i i did video production for
my local church
since 2002 and three
and so
i was in the very skill sets that i
needed to delegate so that i could run
other parts of the business
but ultimately
if you delegate something that you
currently do a lot of times you will be
blinded by your ego and just thinking
that nobody can do it as good as you and
that's just not true but honestly that's
what i thought and i'll never forget
early days of think media when i'm in
the solopreneur season i've got enough
money coming in from youtube ads and
affiliate marketing i start working it's
it's paying my wife's my wife and i's
bills and we actually start working with
a video shooter and editor named jay he
wanted to intern first and once he kind
of like got up to speed then we i
started to pay him for editing and i'll
never forget i'm kind of mentoring him
through that we overlapped you know
through a few episodes where he'd watch
me edit and he happened to be local in
vegas here
so anyways
uh eventually he edits his first solo
episode that's going to be released on
think media and you will never believe
the amount of
drama in my mind i'm thinking to myself
oh my gosh i can't believe tomorrow
we're releasing one of the j edits i
mean i watched it he had grown but i'm
still like that's not how i would have
done that part that's not how i would
have done that part oh my gosh and i'm
like today's the day that think media
dies when we release this video the
audience is going to turn and say what
when the heck did you get a ghostwriter
when did you sell out like when did you
just stop even being a creator did you
sell your creator soul this is literally
keeping me up the night before i'm like
i'm like the comments are gonna cancel
me like this is this is my end it's been
a nice run up until here and and it's
all downhill from here and so i released
the video
and i want you to guess
how many comments on that video
mentioned
that there was different editing how
many do you think do you think it was 20
comments do you think it was 15
do you think 10 people were like this
the vibe is different wow the editing is
different what's different about this
episode
well you're right
zero people
mentioned the editing
which backfired because not only was i
happy that i didn't get cancelled
i was a little bit disillusioned that
maybe i wasn't the hot stuff that i
thought it was when it came to editing
and that acts actually i needed to check
my ego and trust others see we think a
lot of things matter a lot more than we
think they matter of course you got to
uphold your brand and uphold excellence
and have standards and set that culture
but don't overestimate yourself and
underestimate others
a lot of youtube entrepreneurs stay
stuck because they just never delegate
trust anybody else and they don't check
their ego they just over inflate how
good you think you are at whatever
trust people trust others take a risk
don't be overly judgmental when the
first time they try something not being
able to read your brain read your mind
or you know it doesn't come out what you
actually end up finding is that their
skill sets will be
amplified when you start sharing and
delegating things and that brings us to
number five
i will take
calculated risks
here's your fear i'm guessing with
hiring because this was my fear what if
i find somebody i commit to paying them
upwork.com 10 bucks an hour 15 an hour
18 an hour minimum wage local 10 bucks
an hour whatever state you live in or
wherever you live in the country or
maybe you're you're you're humming and
you want to hire somebody that's 20
bucks an hour 25 whatever
what if
i hire somebody
and i pay them for 10 hours of work in a
week at 25 an hour that's going to be
250
and they don't work out
oh my gosh
i will have lost that 250 now i'm not
minimizing i don't know where you are
financially
but we have this thing in our mind like
what if i hire somebody
and i literally work with them for five
hours a week
for four weeks in a row
and they don't work out
then just get somebody else like just
keep going like it's get that's you're
gonna be okay
like you've been watching reruns of
seidfeld for five hours a week for the
last four like
you're not actually that worried about
your time i know your personal life
because i spy on you through your webcam
right now listen like ultimately
you gotta take calculated risks
what if i hire the wrong person you will
like i actually promise you
once you step into hiring like not
everyone's gonna work out and that's not
even necessarily
says anything about the individual it
just might not be a good fit like call
their vibe might not vibe with you you
might not vibe with them it's not what
you thought it was it's not what they
thought it was they you do you have
standards you give them a shot they
don't quite get to where you thought you
wanted them to get whatever it is like
you just got to go faster you got to
stop and and here's the the worry we're
so we're like penny pinching in the
middle like what if i what if i pay a
virtual assistant
ten dollars an hour online for five
hours a week it's 50 bucks a week let
the money go dude like where where's
your bigger vision are you trying to
build a six-figure business a multiple
six-figure business if like you're not
even playing the game
mentally you haven't developed the
mental toughness
to run a multiple six-figure business if
you're losing your mind over 50 bucks in
a week to just have somebody help you a
little bit to help you get to that next
level i get it i with been there this is
the mind the things that have gone
through my mind as well but you got to
take calculated risks i'm not saying be
stupid the other extreme is like you
know what i don't even have the money
but i'm going to take a loan and pay
someone a salary and just hire them
full-on i don't even know them yet like
you got to chip away at this when you're
building up your business work with
contractors first
like work don't don't go in
think media didn't have employees until
like three years into like multiple six
figures a year as contractors kind of
like working like we're today i feel
like we just put on our big boy pants
and like we have an hr department that's
like the last three minutes at think
media like you chip away at this brick
by brick take
calculated risks
one of my mentors brett johnson says it
this way scared money don't make money
and that might actually be where you are
today one of the things that's holding
you back is fear
of of of spending some money on your
business
well i don't know if i want to invest in
kajabi to host my online course and my
emails like it's just
like secured money don't make money so
instead i'm gonna i'm gonna start
studying every night how to code i'm
gonna build my own wordpress site build
my own plugin to host the email i'm
going to borrow my brother's server and
make my own email server because i don't
want to pay for active campaign i'm
going to like ask jimmy from down the
street to be my cameraman even though
jimmy has bifocals and he can't actually
see
and i'm just gonna like if if you're
rolling with that mentality scared money
don't make money you got to invest in
the software like take a risk and hire
the person hire the contractor invest in
the online course like why are you going
so slow take calculated risks
entrepreneurs take risks look it up in
the dictionary look up the word
entrepreneur in the dictionary and it's
somebody who starts a business at higher
than normal risk the word r-i-s-k is in
the definition of entrepreneur it
doesn't mean you're stupid it doesn't
mean that you overspend but it means
that you got to put the money in man you
got to invest in your business a report
studied that content entrepreneurs on
average invest ten thousand dollars this
is people like you that want to go full
time on youtube ten thousand dollars in
getting their business started and it
takes them 26 months before they're able
to support one's person in their
business it means you got to have a
vision it means you got to invest it
means you got to invest in people you
got to invest in yourself and you you
got to take calculated risk scared money
don't make money all right the last two
number six i will invest in my business
and i will invest in people these are
commitments
i will take calculated risk that's a
commitment i will invest in my business
and i will invest in people that is a
commitment it's a decision to say
oh cool i made a few bucks like let me
uh you know i'm gonna go buy an xbox
like okay i'm gonna go get into a car
payment of a car that's beyond where i
really am financially like oh cool like
no i'm gonna actually reinvest a in my
business
at every stage and i'm actually gonna
reinvest and invest in people
that's the power of the mindset of
hiring when should i hire as soon as
possible
and you should invest in people not just
because it'll help your business go
faster but because this is the purpose
of small business it changes lives small
businesses are the hope of the economy
why you are helping others you're
helping others feed their families raise
their kids like you're stimulating the
economy by creating value with your
business creating revenue and flowing
that revenue to other individuals and
families
being a youtube entrepreneur is one of
the best ways you can impact the world
not just with your content and your
message not which just with the money
you make but the money you flow
into
economies
so you make a decision i'm going to
commit to thinking this way i'm going to
commit to investing in my business and
investing in people here are some
commitments i will share wealth and
success with others
how awesome is hiring like what a what a
joy and a privilege to work towards that
goal so you could share wealth and
success with others i will hire listen
before i feel ready or before i think i
can afford it
i promise you you're probably never
gonna feel ready when should you hire as
soon as possible and you need to do it
before you think you're ready or before
you think you can afford it usually
here's what here's the key you hire for
growth
challenges a lot of times the growth
isn't there yet
so of course you take calculated risks
but you gotta you gotta kind of lean
into that you get you're smart with it
but when you hire before you think
you're ready and you hire right and
you're patient and you check your ego
and you you delegate but you don't dump
and you slow down and train the person
what ends up happening is you you're
gonna go faster you're going to earn
more you're going to make a greater
impact and and then it's going to build
your confidence so you want to take
small steps you don't take giant leaps i
do think it's smart to be wise and
calculated but you want to hire
before you think you're ready and invest
in people and invest in your business
and then number seven and we have some
final questions for when to make this
jump i'm committed to generating a
surplus of wealth because i need money
for the mission
these are commitments when it comes to
hiring it's actually a commitment to
blow your thinking up a little bit
because sometimes and i get it our
target is i'm just trying to survive
inside household season i'm just trying
to be a solopreneur solopreneur season
i'm literally just trying to pay my
bills
but i want to challenge you
to just think bigger
because a lot of times we'll grow
to the size of our thinking we'll grow
to the size of our vision
you know if we're going to be thinking
anyways we might as well think big
and so are you thinking about generating
hear me a surplus of wealth and
sometimes money mindsets hold us back on
this
but it's not like a surplus of wealth so
you could just be rich and like put a
gold golden
gold toilet seat like in your house or
something like something dumb
it's because you need money
for the mission and what's the mission
whatever your mission is for your
business your youtube channel your
message
and you need people
so if you need people then you need to
be able to pay people so if your vision
is just on enough for you then you don't
have more than enough to expand so if
you're expanding your thinking then your
commitment is like okay
i got to be thinking even better how do
i generate even more money and i know
you're like of course sean i want to
like how do i make money with my youtube
channel but i'm saying how do i build
wealth like how do i 10x my thinking how
do i 100x my thinking in terms of
generating wealth with my youtube
channel and shifting
your focus towards so that
we can make a greater impact we can hire
more people we don't have to like double
should we get this email software or not
this website software or not can we hire
this person to help us or not help this
help us with branding help us build
something can i attend this event or not
can i buy buy these plane tickets or not
no this is all so that i can move the
mission forward i'm committed to
generating a surplus of wealth because i
need money for the mission so when
should you hire here's some questions do
you have time
if right now you actually have a ton of
time on your hands
then maybe you should just roll up your
sleeves to get to work and generate some
money before you hire
if you
second question do you have money
if you have no time and you actually
have money available right now then
you're potentially being irresponsible
because i heard dan sullivan say this
way
if you have
a problem
and
you have
money
you don't have a problem
like you've got resource sitting there
that is ready to be deployed against the
problem now of course well sean you
can't solve spiritual i like i i hear
you talking to me lucy listen ultimately
it's saying practically and then by the
way it's even biblical you know that
solomon wrote in ecclesiastes that money
answers everything and it's not saying
it answers like happiness although i
wonder if you have enough money you know
money's not the key to happiness but if
you have enough money maybe you can get
a key made you know what i mean just go
to home depot listen you get where i'm
coming from money solves problems so
you've got money sitting there you just
need to take the time to actually
point those resources towards somebody
else hire software to help you know or
hire get the software get the service
get the agency get the individual get
the person so do you have money so so do
you have time if you have more time go
use your time to generate money if you
have money and no time
then you need to neither need to stop
doing things or now is definitely the
time to hire because you have resource
and then here's the final question do
you have a clear role
and do you have a repeated task that is
delegatable huge mistake people make
i want to hire and i just need somebody
to like do everything like you ever felt
that way like i just need i like i could
just hire like a person like i don't
know what do you want him to do well i
don't know i'm just so i'm so stressed
out like getting ready maybe they could
like help me get ready they could pick
my outfits out maybe write my scripts
for youtube videos for me maybe they
could like do the keyword research and
then i mean it'd be kind of cool maybe
they could design the thumbnails too i'm
just like looking for a person maybe
man laundry laundry's really hard too so
maybe like
when i'm shooting the videos then after
they wrote the scripts for me they could
like do the laundry for me
and then maybe like they could like do a
bunch of branded photo shoots for me too
because i need that for my social media
like we're freaking delusional dude like
no that that is not a person like unless
your puff daddy literally sean puffy
combs and you get like that the dude
with the umbrella that follows him
around like that guy
probably does everything for puff daddy
but ultimately he probably makes a
quarter million dollars a year or
something like that too you know what i
mean so i chances are you can't hire
brentworth or whatever that guy's name
is
so listen do you have a clear role
do you have a repeated task that's
delegatable
for youtube entrepreneurs it's probably
video editing it's probably the thing
that takes the most time it might be
customer service because maybe you do
coaching or consulting you need someone
to set up a calendly an active campaign
or something
a a calendar for you that like gets
people on your calendar so you can coach
them on zoom do consulting on zoom goes
back and forth with them you identify
anything on your schedule that's taking
your time that's clear
and it's clearly delegatable and then
you go after that one thing hire that
person train them get them going get
that automated get that systematized and
then you can hire somebody else
so when should you hire as soon as
possible and think about what that means
like it might not be possible at this
moment but i would say as soon as
possible and before you even think
you're ready if you want a book on this
uh one book i highly recommend we'll
link it up everywhere
and definitely get this on audiobook or
physically the e-myth revisited why most
small businesses don't work and what to
do about it ultimately this book
revealed that 80 of small businesses
which is youtube creators youtube
entrepreneurs are essentially small
businesses 80 fail mainly because they
never build systems and the whole
business
relies on the work of a single
individual e-myth reveals that you can't
do this alone you can start it alone you
can even build it alone but you can't
sustain it and scale it alone and so
most small business owners work in their
business rather than working on their
business and working on your business is
where hiring comes in it's where
visioneering comes in it's where
thinking about the future comes in and
so i definitely recommend checking out
that
book get help friend i think it's time
it's time to think bigger at least make
the commitment to this journey to keep
learning and i also want to invite you
because this was just the introduction
of really a master class we did in our
program called inner circle and
ultimately in inner circle that is we
have two big programs at think media one
is video ranking academy that's our
online course and community
that's all about youtube how do you grow
on youtube get subscribers on youtube
views on youtube uh how do you make
money on youtube youtube youtube it's
all about youtube eventually though how
do you build a bigger business around
your youtube channel video ranking
academy touches on that lightly our
monthly membership program called inner
circle goes in depth into that an inner
circle we talk about taxes and llc's and
team and all those different details and
so if you're at that stage to say i got
a little momentum i do need to figure
out this hiring thing um this was just
again about 20
of our hiring master you know i need to
figure that out i want to avoid the
pitfalls i don't want to waste the money
that's the power of inner circle is that
you could avoid
spending hundreds or thousands on the
wrong person you could avoid spending
hundreds or thousands on the wrong
software and so your investment into
inner circle should you be ready and if
you want to check it out think
innercircle.com is the website the word
think inner circle dot com is the url
and all the information is there and
that's for those that want to scale
faster go from that okay i got momentum
on youtube and i'm ready to go to the
next level and if you want the full
episode where i really broke this down
it's really a master class on hiring a
team we have had guest speakers in there
talking all about hiring va's their
whole system we introduce you to
resources where you could just shorten
your learning curve on that it's a
pretty powerful program and so i
definitely recommend if you're at that
stage check it out and thanks so much
for checking out this episode on the
think media podcast
wow i mean was shawn stepping on some
toes during that episode that was fire
and if you are part of inner circle i
hope that you've actually gone into your
members area because this was actually
the last training that sean did inside
of inner circle and get this that was
only a portion of the entire training
that he did all about getting help we
dive deep inside of inner circle on the
10 steps to building your online
business youtube is actually just one
piece of that i think of it like this
you know when you think about that
iceberg and then the water and then
everything underneath the water youtube
has actually just the tip of the iceberg
and inside of inner circle we go deep
into the 10 steps for building that
entire freedom-based online business and
for this episode we really wanted to
give you a taste of what it would be
like to be a part of inner circle so if
you've got momentum on your youtube
channel if you have some traction on
your youtube channel if you are ready to
actually build the online business
around it then i would invite you to
join us inside of our monthly membership
program you can go to think
innercircle.com we'll make sure to link
it down below as well as here on the
screen and you can go there and register
on a month-to-month basis or you can
actually save when you purchase the
annual membership we have so many
members from around the world in so many
different niches that are winning on
youtube like benazodi who's part of keto
camp he's built a multiple six-figure
company and has been
so involved inside of inner circle as
he's built out his business nicole eaton
who has built her entire online business
around what we're teaching inside of
inner circle and so many other amazing
people so
if you're ready to join us inside of
inner circle be a part of the ic fam get
discounts to so many great things that
we have here at think media get first
access to things that we release and to
be a part of our inner circle then
definitely go to think innercircle.com
now if you're just getting started on
youtube this is maybe just a taste of
something for the future i recommend
that you go actually to video ranking
academy first but if you're already
getting traction and you're ready to
move forward then inner circle is right
for you and like we do on so many
episodes here we want to shout out
someone from our think media podcast
thank you so much for leaving a review
over on apple so that other people can
see if this is the right podcast for
them i want to thank hundreds of people
who have actually already left a review
and i want to encourage you that if you
are listening to this podcast and you've
not left a review yet then please head
over to apple podcast leave a review
there and maybe you'll be featured on
one of our episodes today i'm going to
feature athena and athena just left a
review in august and she said this
podcast will turn you into a youtuber by
following the tips shared on this
podcast i have improved my skills and
have grown my youtube channel six times
faster than ever before thank you athena
thank you so much for leaving that
review and letting us know that your
youtube channel is growing oh that makes
me so happy to know that the information
you're getting here on the podcast and
over on our think media main channel is
helping you grow and reach your dreams
of growing your youtube channel well i
want to thank you so much for being a
part of today's episode and remember
that if you want to catch the next
training for inner circle you've got to
join us at thinkinnercircle.com
and we'll catch you in the next episode
bye are you ready to start or grow your
youtube channel do you feel stuck and
need help connecting the dots
join this free web class where you'll
learn the step-by-step playbook for
youtube success we've helped thousands
of purpose-driven entrepreneurs just
like you grow their influence with video
register today for this exclusive
training at thinkmasterclass.com